I don't I don't I don't know who he was
I don't know you personally but this is
just a try like I do this all the time I
talk to women four days a week and this
is a trend I see as they submit to the
rapper guy and then he treats them bad
and then they say oh no but I can't
trust men the next guy I need to put up
all these walls I need to make him wait
to have sex I need to make him do this
do this do this and this is the good man
that would actually marry you so the
problem is really the problem is who you
choose as women that is the problem is
you are choosing wrong as women you are
attracted to the wrong things and you
are choosing the wrong types of men and
then what happens is when it goes south
based on your decisions by the way not
the man's decisions or not other men's
decisions who aren't your man when it
goes south what you are trying to do is
make the next man pay for something that
he didn't actually do and so what it is
is that you need to learn to choose
better men from the get-go I don't agree
with that kind of but not really because
you know what the craziest thing is
nowadays is this is why I say being
submissive is also another problem
because when you submissive in the Name
of Love and I'll tell you something he
wasn't just a rapper when I met him he
wasn't because he was a rapper actually
I may even I met him in person through
family friends it was amazing he was an
amazing person and then he had the dream
of wanting to be a rapper and that's how
I supported him his dream right and I
generally I thought oh wow this person's
amazing he just switched on me and this
is the thing I am not you did nothing
out of the Blues by then do you know
when it comes to when it comes to um
it's not that didn't do anything but
there's there's your character is shown
in certain situations you got a choice
to make you can abuse somebody or you
can leave how many years in did you see
the red flag maybe like first second
year so and then you stayed for three or
four yes and is that on you a little bit
because it's accountability but this is
being a psychologist you kind of you you
understand a little bit more about being
a victim of abuse it's not always that
you're consciously making the decision
to stay because you're dumb and you know
no better you get get to a point where
you're insecure and you're depressed and
gets to that stage and this is what I
say about being submissive to a man you
need to ensure that there's trust
respect and there's love because those
three things will make submission make
sense otherwise if you're just teaching
people to women to be submissive all the
time but you submit it to the wrong man
exactly and let me tell you what it what
the problem is because I believe that
for you to be in a successful
relationship you have to be submissive
so as a woman I was submissive to the
wrong person I fell into a trap and this
is what I'm trying to say things need to
make sense it's not just about submit as
a woman you need to create and build a
relationship based on mutual respect
that's the only way submission makes
sense
you'll submit into like bad boys because
that's what majority of females are
attracted to so if you're submissive to
bad boys and the good guy comes you're
not going to be submit you're going to
give him masculine energy before he was
a bad boy he was a good boy hang on okay
so but you submitted one to two years in
so the majority of the relationship you
knew he was a bad boy and you submitted
so so that's what I'm saying he's
correct what he's saying he's based on
he's he is because it's based off the
words that came out of your mouth so
okay I'll go back in that spring okay so
I submitted for one year by then I'm in
love and I'm already think we're gonna
get married you at the end of my life
okay your two things start to go a bit
South year three I'm thinking wow this
is not really great what year was he a
rapper was he a rapper all of these like
probably from your year year one towards
okay so so I'll I'll give you I'll give
you something I'm I'm sorry to stop you
so when so when he's rapping what type
of lyrics are coming out of his mouth
actually and this is the thing he's
talented he didn't no no but everybody
is quite woke no I believe listen to her
listen to what I'm asking you right when
he's rapping is he talking about
money blah blah blah all this kind of
stuff no no and this is this is what I'm
saying I supported him also because it
made sense so he was that it was like a
Will Smith typewrapy he is good he's
quite woke he said he was extremely
talented and he said things in a way
that I appreciate there was value in
these lyrics and this is what I'm saying
that submission submission you fall in
love and then he gets to a point where
he's like nowadays people think
commitment is rubbish people don't
commit I thought actually I need to
commit I've made my choice I found
somebody that I do love although things
are not right I've already submitted I'm
here and I need to commit otherwise
probably I'll end up lonely and have the
feel of the being 13 being childless and
I was in a bad situation with a dog or a
cat which one do you prefer fish they're
prettier and easier you prefer fish yeah
I'll be outside it's some kind of pet
some kind of pet or maybe not have a pet
like a bearded dragon I'll probably have
a baby what's a bearded dragon better
Dragon like an iguana yeah but a smaller
one it's really cute I mean people are
scared but so do you sorry to switch it
day do you think women nowadays
understand what it is to be in a
long-term relationship and hold down a
relationship
do you think women understand what that
is there's a lot of commitment sorry
Linda's right Linda's shaking head sorry
go on Linda no I I don't think
because I don't think
you're still in store
um I just feel as though they put a lot
of emphasis on the physical and I think
if you're dating to get married there
are certain things that you need to
agree upon and I don't think
in my experience with a lot of girls
that I talk to that call me about boy
advice and such I ask what are your
values what it what do you believe in
what are your political what are your
religious if you're religious do you
want does he want kids where do you
where do you want to live in the city do
you want to live in the the sub the
suburbs the countryside they don't know
these things about themselves so how can
you or and even guys too like how can
you how can you date if you don't have
common ground on those things can I ask
you a question how many women are here
there's like there's four of us and we
keep talking about women as if like ask
me if I know what I want I'll tell you
exactly where I want to live oh we can
definitely tell them you would
definitely tell us you know I'm just
saying I can tell you because obviously
I like to speak like this it's fun I
love being fiery fine but I'm sure Angel
knows I'm sure imogeners I'm sure you
know not every single woman okay so what
is it what does it take to be in a long
what do you think it takes to be in a
long-term relationship or hold it down I
think number one 100 your intentions I
think when you meet somebody for the
first time number one normalize dating
for marriage because there's two
completely separate worlds out there
there's dating for marriage and there's
dating uh the Modern Woman yeah the
Modern Man internet dating meeting just
to have sex so let's put that to the
side if you're trying to date somebody
to be with them forever then it's about
your intentions so number one intentions
number two make sure you're compatible
if you're not I always say if I'm dating
somebody then if I'm not going to be
with them for the rest of my life then
why am I going to be dating them if it's
not working and we've discussed things
then I don't need to just be dating you
for no reason so that's it really for me
I think if you're the right person in a
partnership and it's going to work then
it's going to work and then you can hold
it down together and it moves into a
separate conversation about what what
more do you need but I think that very
first basis your best friend you need to
be best friends have the good intentions
together and be compatible and then from
then on everything else you build on
with your partner
[Music]
I feel like I totally agree and you need
to I feel like you just have to like
yeah just what you said best friends
because like without if you're just in a
relationship with this person and you're
not like
you know like close in some sort of ways
like as close friends or anything like
that it's I don't think it's gonna ever
work if it's just sex and all these
things and then yeah I just think that
you should be close I think it's a
massive generation thing that's
different as well like if you look at
you know our parents grandparents it's
completely different completely
different so earlier on when I was
asking you as many of you know I was
just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible